Several European countries have shut their borders to Britain...
...due to concerns over a new rapidly spreading coronavirus strain.
British Prime Minister Boris Johnson announced on Saturday...
...that the new virus strain had led to spiraling infection numbers.
That prompted Belgium to announce that it was closing its borders...
...to trains and planes coming from the UK and the Netherlands to suspend flights.
Italy says it's planning a similar ban and a German health ministry official said...
...restrictions would be imposed on flights from Britain and South Africa,...
...which has also detected a new coronavirus strain.
Austria is also reportedly planning to ban flights.
Spain said, in light of the moves by other countries,...
...it was asking the European Commission and European Council for a coordinated response.
Otherwise, it would act unilaterally  to defend its interests and citizens.